jamas d'accord je vais vous la chanter
et vous la fredonner avec moi
[Musique]
à
avec beaucoup de couleurs
avec beaucoup
douceur
vous rêvez
qui voit lippi les garçons
casimir chantant sa chanson
françois
une volée facile
[Musique]
mais j'aimerais mieux pas si je
là je l'aurais mieux peu si j'étais
vraiment
[Musique]
ah ah
non
[Musique]
dans le kiosque à l'écouté
on dit puis le collier
leur serine citron frais et groseilles
[Musique]
un papillon passer le temps
assis sur un banc j'ai eu
à regarder
puis ténéré
mais je n'aurais même pas si je veux
le jour et mieux peu si j'étais avant
[Musique]
oh
à
non
aux madmoizelles julie pour sûr ce n'est
pas le moment de chanter mécaniquement
chose de grave
j'ai pas voulu en parler comme ça devant
des enfants bon bah tout à l'heure les
enfants nés vous machette venez on va en
parler avec franchement
julie le facteur très vite mais c'est
une véritable délégation et tu es
sérieux en plus un mais vous en faites
une antenne tous les deux que se passe
très bien le facteur vient de me dire
qu'il avait des nouvelles terribles à
nous apprendre c'est vrai facteur ben
voilà il s'agit d'une lettre dans tous
les habitants de l'île ont reçu un
exemplaire aujourd'hui la même lettre
exactement pour tout le monde voici les
autres tenez julie françois sitac terre
trembler de peur habitants de l'îlot
z'enfants mois le dernier des
descendants de la famille des féroces
tyrannosaure chassés de l'île par les
casimir us je reviens aujourd'hui
reprendre possession de moon il fuyait
tous avant mon arrivée mais laissées sur
place tout ce qui se mange car j'aurai
grand cette impression ne rentrent pas
vrai ça qu'il existe encore des
tyrannosaures vivant c
c'est ahurissant mais je vais regarder
ce qu'on dit sur les tyrannosaures dans
mon dans mon dictionnaire
voilà voilà voilà la page 10 à 12 heures
le tyrannosaure et est un reptile dont
le corps pouvaient atteindre 15 mètres
de long et 5 mètres de haut c'est d'en
mesurer 20 cm c'est le plus grand de
tous les carnivores de l'histoire du
monde les squelettes plan a retrouvé son
vieux au moins de 65 dany pour sûr ça
l'a fait loin
il vaut mieux être très prudent vous
avez raison facteurs mais s'il s'agit d'
taf aux tyrannosaures il vaut mieux
mettre les enfants à l'abri médiatement
vous avez raison françois rime 10 et les
je vous suis entendu facteurs julie tu
nous aides oui oui je prends quelques
objets dans mon casque et j'arrive à
parfait les enfants les enfants venez
vite
aller julie tu te dépêches pas dégueu
vent je vous rejoins
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'horrible à tyrannosaur est retenu
il n'y a plus personne je vais pouvoir
me régaler tranquillement
sais-tu c'est une bonne farce tenons bon
jeu les unes de ses fins
[Applaudissements]
mais que fais tu là je
t'attendais
mais n'a pas eu peur du terrible
tyrannosaure pas du tout parce que je
savais que le terrible tyrannosaure
c'était toi mais enfin comment en tout
deviné
et bien parce qu'un vrai tyrannosaure
n'aurait pas mis au bas de la lettre
laisse moi s'il te plaît les dragées au
poivre de l'état géré duo
[Musique]